all right another saga of weekly mcu
episode videos is upon us kind of like
clockwork at this point but first yes i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by
shopify shopify is the leading commerce
platform with the best tools to start
run and grow your business they have
empowered over 1 million entrepreneurs
worldwide to achieve independence and i
appreciate that and that brings me to
the meat of this segment shopify is
giving you that peek behind the curtain
of real entrepreneurs and that's what
their new documentary owned the room and
i for one love the motivation i love
what this
is it serves to show all of us
all of you that you can be entrepreneurs
too because that's the biggest hurdle
right
overcoming that voice in your head that
says oh no entrepreneurs
they're different somehow you know it's
like well like me they're them and
they can do that i can't don't listen to
that voice that voice is giving you bad
advice
and if any of you out there are
interested in becoming entrepreneurs or
achieving that dream that might seem so
unattainable
it's worth a watch it's on disney plus
right now i assume if you're
watching this video you might have
disney plus already why i put it on here
click the link below you can find out
more check out the trailer give it a
look-see and maybe you too will find
your
spark because you need your spark to
become that's right
a planeswalker but also an entrepreneur
and thank you once again to shopify for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right so falcon
in the winter soldier at least the first
episode a falcon in the winter soldier
that's what this video is about because
i'm not you know
clairvoyant but this is a spoiler
warning for the first episode of falcon
and winter soldier in these videos
i get a little spoilers when talking
about episodes you get it so falcon in
the winter soldier really you know what
i liked about it
is that it it's the emotional depth
of sam and bucky it was a great
reintroduction to these characters you
know it's like sam doesn't feel worthy
of the captain america shield he's like
who am i to be captain america there's
only one captain america he was cap i'm
not cap
even though cap himself was like i
choose you to pass the torch
bucky gave the knot of approval but sam
has that self-doubt like how do i fill
those shoes you know it's
kind of a lesson about self-doubt don't
do that when some
great person passes that torch to you
you take that torch otherwise some
corporation is going to make the
soulless move of filling it for you and
it's not going to be as good you see sam
and his sister trying to make ends meet
they're trying to get a loan and the
bank's like well you don't have any
credit for the past five years i'm like
i know
i was disappeared you know how that goes
that thing that happened that you
definitely know happened
it just sucks it was tough to watch but
it's totally how it would
be that's exactly which means thanos was
wrong
i mean it's safe to say at this point
thanos was wrong you know the world
looked like it
sucked after the blip after the snap
even in juan divisions this is what juan
division and falcon in the winter
soldier
the the series the shows they're
illustrating that you know thanos was
wrong
director dick was like you don't know
how hard it was after the blip
things were rough things were tough and
after everyone
came back it's like we don't have the
infrastructure to support
these billions of people who came back
that we totally thought weren't coming
back
might be more of a lesson of how earth
doesn't roll well with things because i
mean i suppose the snap
would work in a world that is black and
white
doesn't deal with any gray areas but
earth and all its people on it
we all deal in the gray though we like
to think we deal in black and white we
don't things are never so simple so i
guess the snap was never gonna work so
yeah sam's emotionally dealing with all
that then we have bucky who's dealing
with his ptsd from
all of his time as the winter soldier
all the wars he's fought
not even wars all those times he was a
murder machine for
hydra yeah that's more apt all the
innocent people he kills just like
it's easy to see oh yeah bucky he's
awesome he was bad because he was
brainwashed it wasn't really bad he was
a victim
but now he's good it's like yeah but
he's also really hurting mentally
i like the fact just it doesn't just
gloss over that like oh yeah all that
time is the winter soldier
he just doesn't think about it no he
will cause like i said in captain
america civil war
i remember all of them he remembers all
the victims and you see that playing out
well there's this guy this old guy he
hangs out with
and he was like oh he's just making
connections with people and then you
find out oh
this dude's son winter soldier killed
him
oh this is going to be really bad that's
going to be really it's going to be a
conversation he's going to have to have
with this guy it's either going to be a
conversation he has
or this old guy is going to die before
he has a conversation and bucky's never
going to feel that fulfillment
which would probably be worse but i can
see them doing that but as long as this
old guy's alive
bucky in order to get that off his chest
is gonna have to have that conversation
it's
that's gonna suck so that's what i like
about this episode it shows sam and
bucky are dealing with this heavy
emotional strain
it really gets to showcase anthony
mackie and sebastian stan's acting i
like how we get to peel away the layers
of the characters
and the actors get to shine in that way
but it does start out with an exciting
action sequence
action sequence is no joke either it was
i was like this looks like a movie this
looks like a big budget summer
blockbuster movie
because it's the biggest studio on earth
backing it so it's going to and they're
not going to get sued by fox for it
totally reminding me of independence day
because they own fox now so that works
out too i'm not saying it ripped off
independence day i'm saying
i thought of independence day apparently
you can't have a chase sequence
among a rocky ravine a canyon without me
thinking of independence day then we
have these other baddies who when i saw
their masks i was like oh
so this is the gargoyle's crossover i've
been waiting for him this is live
action gargoyles i know it's not i'm
still holding out that a live action
gargoyles will happen
ever in my lifetime disney come on
you've given some great stuff and you've
churned out some crap
both in your time you're not gonna give
fans something they definitely want
cause they do we do back to falcon in
the winter soldier but yeah okay so it's
not the three scratches like gargoyles
no it's a red hand
so is the lord of the rings crossover i
know lord of the rings with the white
hand
though i feel like in lord of the rings
online were there orcs that had
the red hand feel like i'm remembering
it like that anyhow robbery goes down
there's one dude who totally looks like
he has the super soldier thing going on
looks pretty strong and agile which if
we're jumping to the end of this episode
i feel like the obvious thing would be
like oh
is that captain murica not captain
america no captain murca would be the
obvious thing is like oh the super
soldier baddie is
also fake captain america he's one
calorie not america enough that should
be a slogan private america
how many names can we come up with for
this guy a corporation would totally do
that if there was a captain america and
captain america was gone i imagine that
captain america would be like hey
friend of mine sam you've put in the
work you've earned this you
are the next cap and if that person was
like i don't feel right you know what we
should just retire this shield
some corporation would be like yeah
totally
okay let's market some action figures
you ready to really spit in the face of
man that was brutal the funniest thing i
saw was this meme
of it showed that guy and then it was
harry potter and he was going
how dare you stand where he stood yeah
we did collectively think that who is
this guy
who is this jackoff dick move for sure
moments like that i feel like this is
hollywood
snitching on themselves like they're
telling on themselves and they don't
know it this message of fake moral
posturing and corporate dickery for the
sake of twitter
so hollywood also that message brought
to you by hollywood but hey i like that
show's talking about it all right so
falcon in the winter soldier good pilot
episode i really dug it i like the
emotional moments more than the action
scenes though the action sequences were
no joke they were great but it's like
if i'm looking back to juan division the
things i liked about wand division were
the more emotional moments too the more
thought-provoking moments which means
falcon and the winter soldier are gonna
have that
until it ends in a big cgi marvel fight
possibly with a sky beam
and then that'll be that but the road to
getting there should be a very
compelling one all right so episode one
of falcon in the winter soldier have you
seen it why did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]